today on first we feast and complexion
for DJ Paul K will go teach you how to
pimp out your Super Bowl spread it's
going down today we're doing chicken
thighs I love chicken thighs because
they stay juicier than chicken breasts
in a way cheaper
chicken chicken before you cook your
chicken thighs it's good to use some DJ
power of grilling plant the good thing
about using grilling planks is you don't
have to babysit to grill the whole time
you can enjoy the party but you have to
soak these for at least 30 minutes to an
hour because it's wood so when you put
it on the fire the dry wood will burn so
now our wood planks has soaked and we
rinsed our chicken so now we got to Pat
it dry so my lovely sous-chef feet is
gonna Pat the chicken dry we're gonna
use our DJ Paul barbecue rub for the
chicken thighs because that's the best
seasoning for chicken out of the two
that I have now very important you want
to catch the seasoning into the meat
give it a massage baby a massage now you
can flip them always both sides as you
can see using these wood planks no fire
would get to your meat so we're gonna
close this lid you don't want to throw
your meat on there right now you want to
give it a 10 to 15 minutes so the wood
plane starts smoking when they start
smoking that's when they ready and
that's where you throw your meat on them
beautiful Fifi now we're gonna put our
chicken directly on the grill in place
perfect we got eight pieces on two
planks and we're just gonna let that sit
on there
alright so now just finish it off my
chicken
just touching them up a little bit and
they're gonna look beautiful for my
company there you have it
ties with DJ Paul barbecue sauce DJ Paul
barbecue rub let's put these days on
some poles let's go for more of my Super
Bowl recipes click on the videos to the
right
for everything else keeping like the
complex